hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream our
70th i believe it is 70th my goodness
that is a lot of live streaming
much more than i ever imagined you know
back for example in high school
[Laughter]
yes indeed yeah i i was thinking small
back then with regard to live streams
right no i just much more limited but uh
no it turns out uh there's more room on
the internet than we imagined back then
yes indeed back in 1987
1987 the date of our uh our graduation
as i recall i sort of recall indeed yeah
in which you gave a resounding speech
i gave a speech which i did not prepare
well enough but i think it worked it
worked out let's put it this way i
didn't really i'm like man i didn't
graduate
so all right uh so welcome everyone
today
um we are going to talk a lot about dr
seuss today and in preparation for that
uh what i tweeted in anticipation of
today's show on a fine weekend day a few
months before may two people will talk
about walking the walk and feeling like
frogs
in a rather warm pot so we are going to
begin today
with a poem that you have written and
you are actually a remarkable poet
uh and then we're going to talk about
some of the amazingness that is dr seuss
some of the lessons that he has taught
nearly all of us over the years and then
we're going to talk about some of the
current pushback against against zeus
but first just a few announcements as
usual please
consider joining us on one or both of
our patreons at either of them you can
get access to the discord server where
there are lively conversations going on
and other various other benefits at each
of each of those at brett weinstein or
heather hein's patreons
and we want to say as we have not
maybe said in a few live streams how
grateful we are
for all of your support especially
especially as things continue to go off
the rails in surprising and new ways
we are we are so grateful to know that
there are people out there who are
appreciating
uh what we're doing and uh the way that
we are
allowing ourselves to think in public
indeed
a couple mundane things uh
one we had a lovely conversation uh with
the coalition of the reasonable group
this morning you did on your patreon my
patreon
i will say uh be aware the time has been
shifted to nine o'clock
that is a permanent change to give us
room before live streaming
um that time will also be nine o'clock
for tomorrow's conversation
about evolution and also a benefit of
the higher tier patreons for you
the higher tier patreon um so uh please
join us at nine and we will find a way
to change what it
says about the timing on patreon the uh
it's simple let's just let's move on
all right but uh in any case uh there is
that we will be giving away
a another invite to
uh clubhouse because we have not
destroyed enough lives yet
by our accounting and um all right i
think with that
we are oh if you uh want the invite to
clubhouse
um i believe you put uh hashtag
clubhouse in the chat
someone in the chat will i don't know
we'll uh tell you what the correct
procedure is okay okay so without
further ado we are going to
talk about dr seuss beginning with a
poem that you have written
this week i have written a poem i will
say i'm a little nervous about reading
it
it is possible to lose a cadence in
there and i beg your forgiveness if that
happens but
without further ado wait it's it appears
to be
so i have not heard it yet i'm looking
forward to it and it appears to be
written
by one dr weinsteinium which is how i
refer to you sometimes when you
call me on the phone and we yell at each
other yes there's just
there's a story behind this we'll we'll
get to it later but yes
this is let loose the seuss by
dr weinstein my sense is that now they
have gone
far too far the offenses they claim have
grown just too bizarre
they say dr seuss wrote books that did
harm that we shouldn't be fooled by his
fanciful charm
but they must assume that we're dumber
than dumb that we'll take their word and
go
numb and succumb but i think they've
guessed wrong or at least we can hope
that no one of sound mind could be such
a dope like everyone else dr seuss had
his flaws
he made some missteps and got dirt on
his paws but he owned his mistakes made
amends
and grew wise illustrated his growth as
his heart grew in size
zeus was a model of how we should behave
in confronting our flaws we should all
be so brave
and if we are able put lessons to rhyme
for a rhyme drives a point with rhythm
through time
as for those with an urge to burn
witches and books we should face them
with courage and susan looks
we should block them with baffles that
baffle them good so our descendants will
know where it is that we stood
let them read dr seuss let them read it
i say let them read the whole catalog
don't you take it away it's not yours to
take it belongs to us all
your authority's fake and your bluff we
now call
straight to hell with this wokeness kids
can handle the truth
acquisition of nuance is the purpose of
youth if we shield them from slights
jabs and bumps they'll grow
weak they'll fear violence and innocent
words that we speak
and who wants to live as a quivering
wreck minds like a sieve hiding under
the deck
have them come up stand out tall and
robust
although history's full of events most
unjust that's not the whole story
no not by a lot we've made progress
aplenty in both fairness and thought
though we've miles yet to go and we've
no time to rest the west is best suited
to master this test
so we must protect it stand fast and
defend
values that must never be brought to an
end equality is good a most worthy
objective
it must be defended from naive invective
now we must keep on and continue to
strive
to keep progress going and keep hope
alive doesn't matter your color your sex
or your creed
opportunity is the thing all sneetches
need irrespective of stars that they
have or they don't
regardless of things that they will or
they won't we know how to fix this
it's in all those books lodge now deepen
our minds and the crannies and nooks
have a look and you'll see seuss is in
there i swear so give him a good dusting
off if you dare
he taught us a lot that we now need to
know how is it he knew all the places
we'd go
i'll now leave you with this one final
thought
i'm aware of the hard place in which
we're now caught and i've noticed the
rock
that is blocking our exit i know all
about trump and joe biden and brexit
i've read about covet and lockdowns and
masks
in light of all that i have the smallest
of asks can we please cut it out and not
cancel and mock
can we team up together to dislodge this
rock because we do need to exit this
historical phase
do you get it yet or must i rephrase
we're all in it together
you can like that or not bound up as one
we will prosper or rot
we have one tiny earth it's all that we
roam that's what astronauts tell us when
returning home
and i'm sure that they're right as i'm
sure you're aware so treat this rock and
each other
with the greatest of care
all right oh it's wonderful that's so
good thank you
so two points about it one liberalism is
back
and it rhymes and two dr candy i want to
talk to you about anti-racism and what's
wrong with it so please come on
darkhorse
i don't
i'm not sure that kenny deserves to be
anywhere close to that poem
well um or or the over of dr
seuss um i hope that i'm wrong
i hope i hope that he can um rise
out of the divisive nastiness that he is
helping propagate in the world
and respond to you as he has failed to
uh to coleman hughes for instance
um wow that's that's truly remarkable so
um god seuss did so
i don't mean to call him god sues
sorry um okay i'll call him godzilla's
god zeus
did so many amazing things and i have
heard
some of the weak defenses of him um
sound like oh but aren't they fun books
aren't they warm
books aren't they inviting and lovely
and
okay but that is that is the way in
right like that is that is why people
are interested in going you know
just just as um i believe and i'm not
familiar with this part of their work
but both orwell and huxley wrote a bunch
of
highly analytical fairly abstract essays
what we know of them
are 1984 and brave new world right like
these
these the dystopian futures that they
imagined for us
that were also reflected in the rest of
their thinking but we do it through
narrative and through imagery and
through fiction and through poetry
right like that's that's the best way in
so um here are just a few of the
lessons which many of which you have
alluded to
or directly brought up in that poem of
yours that i find in the lessons of zeus
the value of compromise the problems
with simple rubrics
which is to say he was against
reductionist thinking
embracing who you are not going along
with the crowd
rejecting simple phenotypic markers is
indicative of the value of a person
uh he was anti-war anti-fascist like
actually anti-fascist
and anti-utopian he saw the value of
reaching beyond your own pre-existing
beliefs and biases
he recognized we are not the only beings
of worth or value on this planet
and he saw the wonders of childhood and
you know there's so much more but just a
few and let's just
talk as we as we go through these um
with regard to a few of those themes and
what they're in
um you know the value of compromise
and and the the limiting nature of
stubbornness and the problem with simple
rubrics i think is beautifully outlined
in
a relatively uh poorly known story that
was published in the same volume as the
stitches which i
would talk about more but i've talked
about several times on the show right
um and the the star-bellied sneezes and
sneetches without being uh
you know it's maga hats and it's masks
in every situation at all times and you
know it's just these simple tribal
markers
that reduce us all to to little
tiny characters and that therefore
reduce our humanity
as well arbitrary phenotype whether
that's something you put on your head
or something that you are born into
that's right and that's i mean as i said
here arbitrary phenotypic markers
um so but the zax um is one of my
favorite stories and so i find
i i went at one point this week i was so
distraught
it was just so unnerved by the state of
the world
i pulled it down the stairs to the attic
and i announced to you and zach who
happened to be in the same room i said
i'm going to the attic i'm not coming
down
and you thought i might be serious i was
not in fact what i was actually doing is
i told you as i was halfway up the
stairs
i'm going to find the carefully binned
books of children's books that our
children had and that we have saved for
their children's
children to find whatever dr seuss books
we still have
and unfortunately i didn't find as many
as um as
i might have wanted and i'll show a
couple of them shortly but
um well one of them actually before we
get to where i was going one of them i
did find was this clearly from my
childhood because it's in terrible shape
um was one of the canceled books and
we're not going to talk about the cancel
books yet but
and to think that i saw it on mulberry
street is is here
um loved and broken
spine wise um from the probably late 70s
um but one of the one of the sets of
books that i had had as a childhood that
didn't make it uh into our adulthood
uh included the sneetches which itself
included the story of the zacks
um which i have now ordered and it is
actually available but i don't have it
yet so i only have the text for it
um so there's nothing to show here zach
um except
uh that i'm i'm just gonna read this
remarkable
story uh originally published in 1961
um that people even who love dr seuss
may not be fully
familiar with one day making tracks in
the prairie of prax came in north going
zacks and the south goings acts
and it happened that both of them came
to a place where they bumped there they
stood
foot to foot face to face look here now
the north going zach said i say you are
blocking my path you are right in my way
i'm a north going zacks and i always go
north get out of my way now and let me
go forth
who's in whose way snapped the south
going zach so i always go south making
south going tracks
so you're in my way and i ask you to
move and let me go south in my south
going groove
then the north going zach's puffed his
chest up with pride i never he said take
a step to one side and i'll prove to you
that i won't change my ways
if i have to keep standing here 59 days
and i'll prove to you yelled the south
going zach said i can stand here in the
prairie of prax for 59 years
for i live by a rule that i learned as a
boy back in south going school never
budge that's my rule never budge in the
least
not an inch to the west not an inch to
the east i'll stay here not budging i
can and i will
if it makes you and me and the whole
world stand still
well of course the world didn't stand
still the world grew in a couple of
years the new highway came through and
they built it right there
over those two stubborn zacks and left
them there standing unbudged in their
tracks
just somehow i think i've never heard
that yeah it's it was
it was one of my favorites so my father
as i remember it read
um one fish two fish red fish blue fish
a lot to me when i was very young and
then one of his abs two
his two favorite books to read to me as
a child one of them is not dr seuss
but one of them was green eggs and ham
and the other was ferdinand
the story of of the bull who was too
sensitive for the job to which he has
apparently been born
um who likes to sniff flowers rather
than fight other bulls to the death
um so um the
the zax is exactly as we've been talking
for months now for you know tens of
episodes dozens of episodes
um indicative of the problem of simple
rules
that you are told by an authority and
that you
cannot waver from even in the face of a
situation which clearly warrants it
yep we uh we do a good job
i'm looking for a moniker that fits
those of us
in the we remember how to think
uh social group um do a good job
of pointing out the importance of nuance
but i think
what you're saying is that actually
nuance is a companion of dynamism
yes um that these two things are really
what we're talking about and you know
we've talked elsewhere
about the hazard of fixed rules with
respect to raising children or
governance that fixed rules get gamed
and therefore what you need is
discretion built into systems
but that is um clearly evident in many
many seuss stories yeah um and in fact i
mean related to that which i hadn't
it's not in my notes here for today but
um
another value in virtue that we have
talked about a lot and that i from the
very beginning of running those study
abroad trips that i did
and then that that we did in the end uh
is the value of serendipity
of leaving yourself open enough uh that
you
can find yourself in a situation where
you could be surprised where not
everything that happens to you is
predetermined
or pre-imagined either of those things
and you know how
how can how can you experience
serendipity
um by by putting yourself in situations
that you're unfamiliar with
and how can you be open enough to
receive the values of that serendipity
when it happens
well you have to not be operating by
these simple rubrics by well i heard
that
um you know if i go outside my house i
must wear a mask like you know
i'm not sure exactly what that simple
rubric
will do to you know block serendipity
but
certainly it impinges our humanity um
not being able to walk around
outside alone in nature without a mask
for instance
so the uh the thing about serendipity
i think is also close kin
to the idea that the fact of something
having value
is not necessarily connected to your
ability to describe what that value
is right that there is you know the
pursuit of serendipity involves
going somewhere or engaging in something
and uh not knowing why and i think
one of the things that is very clear and
you raise it in the beginning
you're beginning comments about the idea
that you know a tepid defense of seuss
is that these are just fun kid stories
yes no they are not right these are both
serious stories and what people don't
get is that the purpose of childhood you
and i know this
very very well because evolutionarily
this is
an obvious fact in some ways as much as
many people in the area miss it
the the fact of our very long childhoods
is about the complexity of our
adulthoods it's about building adults
who can handle it
right and so soos whether he was
explicitly aware of this or not
um was very much about creating
adults with capacity and so those
stories
recede into history you go years without
thinking about them sometimes
but they also as i alluded to in that
poem
yeah are in us and one thing that i was
shocked about i would say in my life i
have written
two poems that i regard as significant
enough
to remember where i put them let's say
okay
one of them was about uh the telomere
work yeah and the other one was this one
incidentally that poem that you wrote
about the telomere work was very well
received by dick alexander
your advisor and one of my mentors who
also graduate advisor wrote poetry
um you know i would say in for my part
uh i can't write a serious
poem but i can write an ironic poem
right
but here's what i discovered in writing
this oh i don't i
i don't think that distinction is right
um i think the poem you just read to us
is serious
oh but i'm not saying it isn't serious
goofing off is serious business
right so um
here's the interesting thing so i wrote
the telomere poem
in 1998.
yep um i did not
realize at the time that it was saucy
right and it is and
in what way you're not speaking merely
of the meter
presumably the meter the cadences the
license
there's a lot in it that is actually
explicitly
well implicitly susan
at some level all of us who use the
english language
a lot and with some creativity and
you know who were exposed to any seuss
growing up as most
uh english-speaking kids who were
exposed to books at all
uh were exposed to zeus growing up are
downstream asus and so therefore have
have have onboarded some of the susian
thinking and cadence and you know that's
part of why
there is objection to it but it's so
ubiquitous this is this is what i'm
getting at
is that this stuff is actually so deeply
written into
our linguistic software that it actually
comes out in ways that we have no idea
we owe to this pathway
and so the fact that if you were to
compare this new poem which
i i think it took two hours to put it
together it just
sort of very naturally emerged and it's
called let loose the seuss that's loose
um if you compare that to uh
the other poem on the optimism of aging
gerontologists
um you will find that they actually
sound they're unmistakably
uh linked in in the way that they
function um but anyway my my point is
all right how much
there's tremendous amount of profit to
the little linguistic games
that that theodore geisel put us to that
caused us to build circuitry that we use
all the time have no idea it came from
him
and that this now uh you know at the
point that
zeus is under attack right because of
woke nonsense
it suddenly comes flowing out and you're
just amazed at how
actually easy it is that stuff it's it's
very deeply wired in so in part my point
is
those books are for children they are
about creating adults
with high capacity and therefore
the idea of canceling them
is a more of the same it's
of the same sort as um
deciding that math is no good um and so
anyway
the we we will get there of course but
the um the discovery of how deeply wired
in that stuff
is is something that i think it is it is
worth um
it is worth investigating in fact i
would say anybody for whom seuss was
important
should sit down and just try to write a
few verses and see if it ain't there
yeah um and i guess we could ask
you know it's an evolutionary question
to ask
are we all downstream of soos or
was in fact soos effectively channeling
something older yet
that is that is in the cadence of the
english language that is a way
for deep lessons of english um
to be remembered and to be created and
shared
such that you know that there is
something distinctly seussian and i
haven't
thought about it formally enough to
identify you know like
an an excellent linguist would be able
to come up with it right away come up
with a number of the features right away
uh but i think we are as as we have said
now we are all downstream of soos
but also um he wouldn't be as important
ubiquitous as he is
nor would many of us be so able to
immediately
find something in ourselves that felt
susan
if he wasn't effectively channeling
something far older something more basic
fundamental to what english is so again
this is one of these things that we will
find out if i know what the hell i'm
talking about but i think it's iambic
pentameter
that is no i think it's it's something a
little bit different actually um i
just i ran into it today um so
it's not you know it doesn't sound like
for instance
the the shakespeare that is iambic
pentameter right
well i i i'm not going into it obviously
it obviously
isn't strict iambic pentameter but the
question is is it borrowing from that
same kit
you know i do i i really don't want to
go here there's there are a lot of
rhyming schemes and i don't think it's
useful for us without having thought
about it
i'm sure that just as you can build uh
a phylogeny of languages which is uh
remarkable
and you know at some point on here we'll
share some of what that looks like
um that and it but it's noisy it's far
noisier than a phylogeny of
organisms for instance because there's a
lot more articulation because there's
borrowing because
linguistic appropriation you know a
subset of cultural appropriation
is rife and common and glorious and
wonderful
and so it's you can't just build a
simple branching tree it constantly
reticulates back onto itself so too
rhyming schemes will be like that but
even more so even more reticulate even
more coming back on themselves
um but i think just naming the one that
we all know
and saying oh this is that like there
are a bunch of them
and i don't know which which kind of
thing he tends to use and it's obviously
multiple ones so i'm not
i'm not going to get on board climbing
it's the one that we all know the name
of well
i mean a that would this was as i was
writing i kept wondering how much iambic
pentameter was in this thing because
there are places where it does sound
like uh
the shakespearean kind of pattern
um anyway we'll find out but
all right where are we headed so a
number more of
more themes and um you know just the
wondrousness of zeus
before we start talking about what is
what is
you know as your poem implies and as you
began to imply there some of the stuff
that is um
happening right now is a pushback to him
um
[Music]
among other books that see the value of
compromise
how limiting stubbornness could be in
the problem with simple rubrics i would
put green eggs and ham
in that in that category as well it
teaches the value of
trying new things and reaching beyond
your pre-existing biases
in the same vein also but with an
obviously explicitly anti-war message we
have the butter battle book
yep which is uh uh
wonderful um one of my favorite books
that i remember
from growing up that i actually i don't
find in our set i also
it's it's coming but it's not here yet
um but i don't think we actually read to
our children so i wondered if i had
if it wasn't that good um and went
looking
uh this week is i had trouble in getting
to sala salud
uh which um actually okay we've got an
epic tabby on the table trying to make
trouble here
um but i can i think just
show no actually i can't hold on um
boy is my computer not working nicely
with me
uh not really thank you not right now
um oh my god okay so this is just the
um cover yeah please thanks
uh i had trouble in getting to sell a
solu um
and it is you know it's in one way it
seems i think
because so many of the stories of dr
seuss are these you know
humanoid or cat oid uh
critters on adventures right that it
seems like this just your warm and
fantabulous
uh story making hey zach can i have my
screen back
thank you um storytelling
um but really i had trouble in getting
to sola salud which is longer than zach
so i'm not gonna read it
all um is as i see it anti-utopian
it's this it's this kid really um
this humanoid character uh who
imagines that if that he you know sees
the troubles he's having where he is
and some character comes up out of
nowhere and says i'm going to the place
where there's no problems
come with me and they run into problem
after problem after problem upon getting
to get there and he finally arrives at
the gate and there's a
thing in the lock and so you can't get
in but the gatekeeper says ah but i'm
going down the road to the next place
that's perfect why don't you come with
me kid
and the kid says you know what no i'm
actually gonna arm myself
with the skills and the tools that i
need to defend myself against the stuff
back in my home and i'm gonna go home
i'm going to live where home is
and i'm going to be strong
and i'm going to become and you know
obviously i'm using the modern language
but
i'm going to become anti-fragile and i'm
going to see what i can see about where
i am
and find the values in it and become
stronger in it as opposed to constantly
chasing a fantasy that does not
exist i wonder so you're right that
sounds
perfectly anti-utopian and
the question i have is so i didn't know
this book
um and i haven't i i still haven't
shared it with you sorry but i wonder
if um i wonder whether or not
you would find that people who had a
childhood relationship with that book
had an immunity to
utopian thinking at some level i would
not be surprised if
a uh you know if this i mean in some
sense
um i'm wondering a little bit thinking
about
you know what we've barely touched on
here which is that actually in some ways
the
poetry is the easiest part right the
really
difficult part is the illustrations
which are amazingly evocative
yeah um and in some ways
it's a psychedelic experience
for people who can't have
psychedelic experience because they're
children right so the point is this
the world that is presented in these
books
is a place that you would very much want
to go and see and spend the afternoon
and then look around and
engage with the strange creatures and
just while you're talking zach can you
just show my screen and i'll just scroll
through some of these images from
solidly we're not going to read it but
just as you're talking about
like being able to you know it's
children who are in some ways
living psychedelic experience right
every day
well they and then they mature out of it
and then maybe they can choose to engage
in it explicitly and intentionally
but um that that is part of what zeus
allows you an inroad into
right but you know the thing is
psychedelic experience
is for both better and worse about
um mind hacking
and so the point is that in in the wrong
hands that can be a disaster
in the right hands if somebody who knows
that utopianism
is an attractive idea that results in
atrocities
and they try to teach you this lesson in
a fanciful harmless way in effect
this is the evidence of the opposite
that this is the safe way to discover
the danger it's not that the language is
violence it's that the language is the
antidote to violence it is the way that
you can discover
that something violent lurks in your
desire to perfect the world in this case
the fact that you can't get to utopia
isn't
the end game if you try right but um but
nonetheless you know every time i
i see these illustrations there is some
childlike part of me
that wants to see that contraption
definitely wants to look at trees that
look like those trees whatever they are
right wants to see the trees wants to um
figure out if the physics of that crazy
thing actually works right exactly
and and you know every time we do see
really weird trees in the world
right baobobs or whatever right you and
i always comment on the sushi and
nature first time we saw baobobs in
western madagascar both of us are like
this is a sushi and landscape 100
and then oh my god south and southern
madagascar with the ditterie ace those
crazy tall
like everything in madagascar
practically associate it
and i mean that's that's part of also so
i think you can giving my computer back
now zach but that's
that's part of how you know the basis i
think for the cancellation too and
like again i want to talk about what's
amazing about him first here but
um like the fact is that he was
i believe an american and a white guy
with
um the you know somewhat but really not
very but somewhat provincial world view
of a guy who was rooted in his
particular space and time
yeah and to the degree that he had been
elsewhere
um and he saw the amazingness of what
was not his home what was elsewhere for
him
he reflected on it with admiration and
joy and love
and amazingness and yes there was some
there was there was some racist stuff in
the early early stuff of kids
but um but his reflections
of people who haven't had my experience
my seuss's experience um actually live
these
amazing other lives is exactly what we
should all be hoping for it is what the
value of travel is it is with the value
of
reading stories from other cultures are
and talking to people from other places
and engaging with everyone as if they
have something valuable to offer
and god damn it it's perfectly
democratizable
yes right so in in a sense um
unfortunately and you know as as uh
as a liberal and i'm sure as a fellow
liberal you will resonate with this
one of the great shames of the west is
that
our schools are radically unequal right
if you've got money you get better
schools and that matters
right you can't easily democratize that
it should be democratized we should
insure it
but you can't easily do it on the other
hand seuss books
are very inexpensive and the point is
anybody who speaks the language is in a
position
to benefit from them equally and so
you know i i really do feel as an adult
that some fraction of the schooling that
actually worked for me came from soos
without ever stepping in a classroom
yeah
and you know given that it's
i mean the great thing and this actually
goes to mark robert's point about
um uh the mario brothers effect he calls
it
that the motivational stuff on the
screen that causes you to learn the
pattern of hitting buttons
is a model for education you and i have
said that education shouldn't
be painful it should feel like games and
experiences and
things that you want to do so you don't
even know you're in school well this is
like that it feels so much like
fun that it is now failing to have
the proper defense because it seems
frivolous when it is anything but
it is highly constructive yeah no the
the
concern now is being dismissed as if
it's a you know more right-wing nuts who
are complaining
and why the hell do you care right it's
children's books at the same time
that all the modern children's books
that i can f that you know
actually i didn't go looking at
children's books but a few years ago as
i've said on this live stream before i
went looking for young adults but
young adult books why a books um at
powell's at the extraordinary massive
independent bookstore in downtown
portland
um and i was appalled
at um at the choices available and
really could only find books that were
now considered classics
um like you know like essie hinton um
the outsider
the outsiders said yeah yes
um and um and such that
weren't just so broken by wokeness um
that uh they didn't you know they read
like a slog you know they
the art of course is compromised when
the ideology is first and foremost you
know
there's a reason reason that soviet
propaganda for instance
didn't pass for lasting art
right like the propaganda is propaganda
and most good people
most like without ever thinking about
why or being conscious of it and be like
okay
if ideology came first here um this
isn't
this this isn't fun and it isn't
probably
right either or at least it causes
people almost everyone to sort of go
wait what what is that like what
actually
are they trying to do to my head here
well it's uh it's an analog really
to the comparison that we used to make
in the teaching environment that the
proper role
of a professor is to teach you how to
think not what to think right
we used to say that a lot and in this
case i feel
like the thing about soos is that he
very much taught you
how to think and the details of what
is in the books are irrelevant for one
thing they're so fanciful that
they don't map directly it's the general
lessons and the ability to play with
language and all of those things
and so you know the comparison between
some finger wagging
why a book that tells you exactly what
to think about some complex topic and
pretends it's simple
versus uh you know seuss who takes
uh shows you just how complex
simple things can be made if you juggle
them properly
um yes uh it's a it's a power tool
yeah yeah it it is it's a power tool so
um
maybe we talk a little bit more about
the speeches and or maybe you really
between what we've said on this show
before and what you say in your poem
that's sufficient but it's exactly about
the virtues of not paying attention
to frankly arbitrary phenotypic
characters when you're deciding
um who to associate with uh who to who
to
um you know what to identify as you know
it you know obviously
you know being being female being black
being from eastern europe you know
whatever it is whatever it is that you
were born as
that you had no choice in and you cannot
change um
does partially define who you are
and it means that there are differences
between you and those people who do not
share that particular marker
but the idea that that should rise in
primacy to define who you are and who
your social groups are
and um and give you a sense of whether
or not
um you belong in a place you know even
when
society you know does have vestiges
or often more than vestiges of actual
racism of actual sexism whatever it is
individuals should obviously be doing
the opposite of that
and that i will argue is actually
necessary if not sufficient to change
the society-wide racism for instance
that persists right like it's
individuals
first and frankly a lot of the a lot of
the crazy that's happening
is again this conflation between
individual and population
and the people who are making the woke
arguments can't keep it straight like
they don't actually know what they're
doing
and they will say things for instance
about the snitches
um that it's you know it it
makes the mistake of arguing uh that we
need to
uh we need to ignore our oppression like
no
no it doesn't it says don't identify as
the thing
um that is oppressed and as more and
more and more people do that
and recognize that whether or not you
have a star on your belly or not
is actually not indicative of any deeper
truth about you
then then we will start to see the big
you know the the wheels of state start
to change
yeah it's um well i'm struck by
i actually now feel short changed given
the depth of these lessons because you
know
you and i had only partially overlapping
susie and experience as a child and i
almost feel and feel actually some sense
of loss now with respect to our own kids
that we didn't you know recognizing the
value
we're recognizing the full value a
little late i think and the idea is
actually
i don't know how many things there are
buried in all of those stories that
are of high value and capable of sort of
like
mainlining you know pre-proto-wisdom
into a child's mind
um and you know i i didn't have the
snitches i didn't know about the
sneetches
um i should have had the sneetches yeah
um butter battle i think
emerged a little late a little late yeah
a little late um
but anyway shouldn't shouldn't we have
had all of them and shouldn't we have
put our kids through all of them and
shouldn't this be sort of baseline
we had i mean like we shared sneetches
with with our children i don't know
where it's gone and we don't
know i've i've begun to order them up um
so that we have them right
and not just in pdf form um and you know
there
there are six that will no longer be
available um we have the one from
you know from my childhood but um anyway
let's
let's
talk a little bit more about some of the
the lessons okay the the
virtues and wonders um so sneetches of
course
um here's
an actually anti-racist by which i mean
like actually anti-racist
like actually anti-fascist not the
modern instantiation of either
candy's anti-racism or the yahoos on the
streets antifa
um anti-phenotype-based judgment of
yourself
is this book the shape of me and other
stuff um
which um is about curiosity and about
accepting and loving who you are
whatever shape you are and it's like you
know this the
the modern woke language around you know
fat shaming
and and beauty norms well god the shape
of me
and other stuff is exactly that lesson
yeah and it and again it tells it
through this amazing fantastical perhaps
hallucinogenic
set of illustrations and language in
which two kids
are just sharing ideas about what shapes
they might have been
and it might be if i if memory serves i
don't have it here you know a chair or a
butterfly or a whale or a
truck or you know any number of things
and
and it lands on the message of
effectively love who you are
love who you are and i also i doubt this
was uh
in any way explicitly on his mind but i
also find
you know in in what we have ended up
focusing on
in in our classrooms the consideration
of um you know the shorthand in our
world is uh that you know we are fish
right right it's a very shocking concept
um it's also not shocking if you
understand the deep story of how
evolution works right that we would be
fish is not so crazy
um but it also you know the idea of
it's an important category that is real
and doesn't mean what most people think
it means
right it doesn't mean what most people
think it means and you know
as i tried to make clear in the thing i
wrote on this topic
is that the not the um let loose the
seuss but
the um was that
the marvelous thing about the
recognition that you know we are fish
that seals our bears is that it allows
you to understand what kind of process
evolution must be if seals are bears
what kind of process is evolution it is
the kind of process that can take a bear
and turn it into a seal
right and then you can kind of infer a
lot about fish
what which eat fish we eat fish and our
fish so
isn't that marvelous um but anyway
it i mean so i don't think he was
pointing in that direction but i do
think there's a way in which
you know all true stories reconcile and
so to the extent that
revealing to a child this lesson about
their particular
shape is actually you know adjacent to a
lesson about actually what did happen to
our shape and isn't that interesting
yeah
um absolutely it's it creates fertile
ground
it does um okay
a few a few more lessons with their with
the books attached and you know
this is not a comprehensive list but um
a lesson to children that they should
reach for the stars oh the places you'll
go
all right um a lesson that we are not
the only beings worthy of consideration
on the planet
i would say both the lorax obviously
which is
about no one is speaking for the trees
it's an early environmentalist
uh message and also horton here is a who
yep right so that one
i don't know how we ended up with what
is called a party edition
i'd like to go to that party i don't
know it's like it's it's glittery i mean
it's not glittery
god god forbid but it's like it's shiny
i don't
like it's but thank you it's metallic um
so i don't know what makes this the
party edition of
horton here's a who i honestly can't
figure that out um
but this this is explicitly you know
again um you know hallucinogenic
fanciful amazing um
imaginings of what other worlds look
like and a belief that other worlds
exist
which is amazing and forward-thinking
and expansive and allows for hope
and a belief in their value whether or
not you can pinpoint either
exactly where they are or prove to other
things other people that they exist
or what their value might be they have
value
other people have value other worlds
have value other ways of being have
value
and have you encountered the story of
orton here's a who in uh
preparing for today or did you know it
before i don't really
you mentioned something and i will just
in the setup for you to read it read the
um
dedication for my great friend mitsugi
nakamura of kyoto japan right
which is going to be relevant here yes
so apparently the story
um dr seuss
was demonstrably
anti-japanese and in a way that was
perfectly mundane
uh in the run-up to our entry into the
war
um but in any case he made cartoons all
actually zach do you have um the you
have that
fifth column cartoon
let's see what you got yeah perfect um
so this
is um a this is
proceeding from this uh anti-japanese
trope of basically uh japanese americans
as a fifth column
and they are is there so it says i can't
quite read it it says waiting for the
signal from home
uh yeah i think that's right okay anyway
the japanese so this is presumably this
is from
during the war or before the war yeah i
think this is uh
just prior this is this is before uh
the internment camps i believe so it's
certainly unfortunate yeah it's
unfortunate
it's you know patently racist well it's
patently racist
again in a way exactly of the moment yes
the country was racist enough
to corral its own citizens and depend on
their rights and depending on when it
happened
it was literally during a world war in
which um
you know in which this was the enemy
right so not explaining it this wasn't
the enemy
these are these are japanese americans
but where
japanese japanese people were the enemy
and so okay there's racism in this to be
sure
um but it is uh
anyway it is a measure of his mindset
which would have been perfectly in
keeping with many people but
so after the war he apparently went to
japan
and had an awakening experience the
dedication of that book reveals that he
made friends in japan
mm-hmm and horton hears and he was in
kyoto
yes okay um so horton hears a who
is the is basically his
encoding of the lesson that he had
learned from his
bigoted mindset to his egalitarian
mindset
it is his encoding of that lesson in a
book for children
and so you know a plus
right i don't know that you necessarily
get an a plus
for just simply never having had the
bigotry if you just simply grew up in
a situation that didn't create it but to
get over the bigotry actually
that does take something we have the
before and after
you just showed a before and we have in
his ubra
horton hears a who and so much else
right that demonstrates
the the growth that is possible for
individuals
and that he encodes it in a way that
isn't you know
it's not an apology exactly it's
far better than an apology it's a
corrective for
future bigotry yeah that you know he's
giving to children
right which is you know it is an amazing
fact
and um maybe the world's most impactful
educator
could well be could we and it's almost
impossible to measure because the
lessons are encapsulated in such a way
that when they unfold you don't even
realize where they came from
yeah that's right um
one of the one of the cancelled books
miguel gets pool
um to me i just uh oh here let me let me
see if i can show it here
um yeah
i also have um
except i can't get to the beginning of
the book
yeah here is the uh image that got
magillaget's pool cancelled so this is a
story
i think most of us did not know this
story until it was
cancelled can we before we talk about
that image just
set it up sure um so zach if you can
show my screen here
um this is this is the cover of the book
and it starts
um with a little boy
fishing in a pool that the farmer says
it's too
the pool is too small and you might as
well know it when people have junk
here's the place that they throw it
and the boy says hmm answered marco it
maybe you're right i've been here three
hours without one single bite there
might be no fish but again well there
might
because you never can tell what goes on
down below the pool might be bigger than
you or i know
there might be it this might be a pool
like i've read of in books uh
connected to one of those underground
brooks
okay so it goes on and on and on and
then we get to zach you can show back
yep we get to uh this image where
i can't quite read it it says some
eskimo fish from beyond hudson bay
might decide to swim down
yeah can you yeah might decide to swim
down might be headed this way
it's a pretty long trip but they might
and they may
so i actually did have this as a child
as well you did
i don't i now that i see it i remember
it unfortunately it's not in our
collection but
but in any case obviously the to term
eskimo is incorrect and offensive in
many contexts
um i would point out that this is not
that itself is going to be news to a lot
of people
right and you know are you know are the
beatles next
when quinn the eskimo gets here
everybody's going to flock to him
um i don't remember him i don't know
that reference
let's just put it this way so you're
saying that there's a beatles song which
uses the word eskimo
and if eskimo is if an image of
fur-necked fish being called escomo fish
in asus book is sufficient to have the
publisher of that book say actually
we're going to pull this because it's
not reflective of our values
then you know what's next perhaps the
beatles because they also use the word
eskimo
right and you know we will find that
because of human nature
this is a problem that is riddled
throughout lots of things so for example
i hope i'm remembering this correctly
the term
anastasi is actually anasazi
is an epithet it is not the term that
the people in question
use for themselves um it is basically
the
navajo word for foe um i believe that's
right
there and then there's uh pueblo people
the pueblo people right and then there's
the
most complex case of all i think which
is
the term indian which is obviously
you know columbus's error thinking that
he was
you know in india or had arrived at
where he was intending to go
misjudges therefore the people he's
encountered
those people have now taken on this
moniker and some people in fact i've
been
challenged inside of clubhouse for using
the term indian as if it was an epithet
which it isn't indians use it for
themselves
i have specifically been instructed by
uh people of native descent
we had a colleague at evergreen who
insisted on who actually got you know
pretty pissed off at um all this fussing
around with all this other language he
said call me an indian and let's get on
with it
you know it's not again it's not the
most interesting thing about me
right you know was his was his position
and um it's true
and it is present in everything that i
do and everything that i am
but spending a lot of time around
exactly what language to use
is a waste of all of our time right and
you know
my feeling is people have a right to
self-define and you know to the extent
that we have a major
you know news outlet for native
americans called indian country this is
something that has been chosen by people
they've taken it on
um you know and what are we to do
frankly with white and black
i've never met a black black person or a
white white person i've met some pink
white people and i've met some brown
black people but
the point is these are not literal
descriptions of anything these are
somebody's moniker
right and so the whole thing is fraught
and we can
either get over it and say all right
look history is definitely not a pretty
place it's got its moments both good and
bad
and let us not read too much into the
particular utterances that we are using
or the particular
choice of you know tropes that show up
in a child's book
there's something very interesting to be
done here i think around
what what language is is a move
away from strictly on a monopoetic
utterances
in which excuse me um onomatopoeia being
uh those words that sound like what
they're describing
um so you know the names that we give to
animal sounds um
interesting though that they often sound
so different between different
languages even though the animals
presumably sound the same um but other
words like crash
or bonk splash splash right um
and that one of the things that
linguists describe
as an indication that that you're
engaged in language
that is more complex is that it's it is
much
it goes far beyond simple onomatopoeia
and that you know things that sound like
what they the things they're describing
is a very narrow version that is what
onomatopoeia is
but you're talking now about like visual
descriptors being exactly the thing that
the word is being used to mean
it's like it's like a visual
onomatopoeia that we are stuck in
and what language is is metaphor like so
much of the meaning in language is
actually metaphorical that
you know the and you know and we get
ambiguity
and you know nuance can be ambiguous and
language is almost always ambiguous and
you can disagree about exactly what you
meant by
a certain word um unless it is nailed
down at sort of the
you know visual or you know sensory on a
monopoetic level
but um to be nailed down to that level
is again an example of reductionist
thinking
is a you know is it's just so narrow
and so it's all trees and no forest uh
that we're never gonna get anywhere
interesting or good and you know it gets
in the way
of the purpose of language the purpose
of language is to convey things and so
it just so happens that if you go to
lone pine california
you won't find the lone pine it fell
down a long time ago
right now it happens that nobody is
offended that we call it lone pine
and there's been no movement to you know
why because lorax no one speaks for the
trees brett
i don't think that's why i think it's
because lone pine has now taken on a
meaning that has nothing to do with a
lone pine
right um i mean this is an excellent
example
i think um there you know all of those
place names that are indicative of a
particular thing from a particular place
in a particular time
you know they don't all need to be to be
kept they don't all need to be kept
but a widespread of a moment we're going
to rename
all the things well we're going to we're
going to stop publication of all of
these things and we're going to rename
all these other things man the school
renamings are amazing
there's there's no consideration of the
cost benefit in any case
right and so lone pine is relatively
simple because the cost of just simply
accepting
that it doesn't describe an actual tree
pretty low
on the other hand dead indian memorial
drive in
southern oregon right now that
always from the first moment i heard
that descriptor
struck me as kallus right dead indian
right who was this what are the
circumstances of their death right
um and you know but the problem is if
you rename it
nobody knows how to ask directions
because that's simply what everybody
understands it to be called
a worst case um i remember from when i
was working with bob trivers in jamaica
as his
field assistant we drove through
a town called black river and i asked
him very naively i looked at i said
that river looks brown to me it was just
it was a silty
river and he said it's not named for the
water
it's named for the people right oh
goodness
right this was a descriptor of the
population that lived around that
aren't aren't most people who live in
jamaica yeah but it was
it was a british naming so i
i guess i'm just i haven't been in
jamaica you had that one one extended
experience
in the field with bob many many years
ago um that just surprises me because it
seems
like those people who don't have dark
skin who live in jamaica are
a tiny minority well i don't know what
the uh i don't know what the meaning
is um precisely but nonetheless
it's sure to be uncomfortable given that
a place was named for the
color of the skin and then you and i ran
into an odd example of this
in um uh where were we
uh the slave market
in uh oh charleston yeah in charleston
south carolina right so the slave market
gives the impression that this is the
place where slaves were sold when in
fact what slave market means so
there's a correct meaning to it which is
historically accurate which is that this
is the place where slaves went to sell
their goods
that they actually had an economy that
they could sell things at the place
i don't remember this yeah so anyway the
point i guess
is look if you want to just scrutinize
the name of every damn thing
wow are you going to find a mess and is
some of it going to be offensive you
better
believe some of it's going to be
offensive is that an argument to change
every offensive thing well at least you
would want to figure out
how much chaos you're going to create by
taking things the names of which people
know
and invalidating those names and giving
them some arbitrary i mean
the school you and i went to uh to high
school at
um it was a marvelous place in many ways
i know what you're doing you know
exactly what i'm going to say
so you should name this school there
will be some people out there who know
it it's uh crossroads
the crossroads school for arts and
sciences in santa monica crossroads it's
not a drug rehab center
it's a high school audience well sure it
sounds like crossroads you know and it's
on an alley
yeah but a charming alley as always go
i found it charming but then again you
were there that might have colored my
vision but in any case
do you remember when you and a handful
of other people literally picked up my
car and moved it
yes okay i do
i recall the front of it being a great
deal heavier than we expected on account
of the engine being there
yes it was a nine-year-old little toyota
but
still you managed to it was made of
metal i assure you
um anyway but in any case the school
was so progressive that instead of
numbering the rooms in the buildings
it it named them according to famous
persons
dostoevsky sure um those are the two
that i remember
um uh facilities
the cities you said i had i had great
books and thucydides and
uh at least once i had english and
dostoevsky
uh and we read thucydides and we read
dostoyevsky there was never a hobbes
room
yes am i recalling we were not they
didn't want to
bring about the nasty british and short
end to our young lives
right and they did not want to i read
daoists with a
veil of ignorance they wanted us to
leave wiser than we were but
in any case they they screwed up the
system
because you never knew where your class
was no no no oh but okay
kind of i mean you were only there for
two years i was there for six
because i repeated grades no because it
was seven through 12. um
but for me i thought it was it was
because
it really was oh i didn't expect us to
be going here today but um
you know it was literally they just
bought up a building here and there
around an alley so they had like an old
body shop there was like an airplane
hangar there was an apartment building
uh and um and they'd converted sort of
um these buildings they hadn't raised
them and
built new buildings i think by now they
have it's a very fancy school by now but
it certainly wasn't when we went there
um but you know like i had french in a
in an apartment building and i had my
film classes in this
in this body shop and such and like you
knew
after you'd been there you're where
thucydides was and where dostowski was
and
um and i was a music major for my first
two years there and so that was in the
airplane hangar but the problem was they
literally
changed where the names of where the
rooms were every year so they didn't
move the rooms around
they just they recycled the names
as if there weren't enough important
people from history and they just like
switched where the
was so that was just this is emblematic
of a uh a failure of their model
they named the rooms after people rather
than plants if they named them after
plants then they would have been stable
in place but you know
plato moves from one part of the campus
to the next that's to be expected i mean
socrates in particular you expect him to
be on walkabout you're absolutely right
and he raises a lot of questions
as to where he's gone exactly
okay uh i don't know how we got there
some way yeah
language i'm thinking we're over an hour
oh we haven't even talked about the
cancellation well that's
that's cool we're gonna keep going um
just a couple
more of the lessons of soos um
reflections on what it is to be a child
um so and to think that i saw it on
mulberry street
is this it was it was you know maybe my
least favorite book of his which is not
very interesting
um but there's this one picture in it
which i think i can find here
that is the reason that the zeus
foundation or whatever
um has uh decided not to publish it
anymore
one picture in a in a long book um a
nope yeah there we go a chinese boy who
eats with sticks
in the lower left so you have the
original version i think i do well yeah
so it he's yellow
his skin is yellow um and the other
people's skin aren't
isn't yellow and um and he's got
a conical hat and a ponytail a pigtail
and uh chopsticks and the uh the clogs
uh oh and the and yeah yep
um
i think in the 70s well this book can't
be i don't know i don't know when this
book is from but
um it's a book club edition rather than
a party edition which is what we have
for hortonwho
um so okay so that was turned into a
[ __ ] who eats with sticks that
actually looks more
worse to me by a lot well i i agree
a chinese boy who eats with sticks of
china i think it's actually been changed
since then i don't think that's the
updated version
that looks like going backwards to me um
because [ __ ]
is you know it's not a term that most
people would use in modern times whereas
a chinese boy who
i agree i agree um but it's possible oh
because of because of the complexity
around the term boy and that that is
used as an epithet it's possible that it
was taken
that if you describe him as a man what
if he was actually a boy
well i agree i mean like certainly what
if a guy was actually a child
and as a result of these drawings being
not a hundred percent
accurate it's a little difficult to tell
how old the person in that picture is
oh my god and you know like eating with
sticks is is
that's racist really so we're bringing
this up because apparently this is the
the
this is the image and text in the book
which is the reason for uh the ceasing
of publication of this particular book
um which actually has a lesson in it
right i mean i think
almost almost all of his books at least
the ones that i'm familiar with do
uh maybe that's just the selective
process that my parents used on me and
therefore we used on our children but
um yeah what do you see as the lesson of
what you think that i
saw on mulberry street i believe that
i've never looked into this book until
this cancellation episode but i i read
it
and the the book is about a child who
feels that the story he knows he's going
to be asked about
what he saw and he feels that the story
is a little sparse
and so he comes up with a much more
fanciful story in which the horse that's
pulling the card turns into a zebra and
all sorts of amazing things happen
and then he's asked by his father as he
knows he will be
what he saw and he reports the actual
story which isn't that fascinating so
it's his fantasy and which can also be
read as it's a series of lies
like the boy is a fabulous as all
children are right as all children are
all children
imagine what could be and what might be
and why be true to them what would you
of others
all of this like that's that's what
children do right
and so the book is in some ways licensed
to do that it's an invitation to do that
it is a recognition that the fact that
you came up with something doesn't make
it legit to report could the book have
proceeded in a way that he reported the
fanciful story of course
because everybody knows there was no
zebra on mulberry street right so
you know the the point is it it is
a scenario that raises all of the
important questions about
you know what is an honorable fiction
what is a lie these things
um and in some ways um the cat in the
hat is almost the the inverse it's like
these these children we are told
actually experience this crazy
um this this crazy thing bless you sorry
um the the children actually have this
menace come into their home and um
and um and he brings with him actually
maybe this is the moment to show what
will be our
our picture oh sure um all right so this
is um
the menace the cat in the hat brings
things one and two into his
into the children's home and this is
actually our children at the ages of
three and five
things one and two who have been dressed
up by their grandmother yes love my
mother
very much and made these costumes so
she didn't just this was halloween we
would we didn't force these children
you said they've been dressed up by
their did you not recall this being
halloween i believe we sent them to
school that way for a month
that explains a lot about them doesn't
it it sure does yeah
why they have not been averse to the
lockdowns i don't know what we're going
to send them to school and next time
so my recollection is that halloween was
always
great because of the amazing costumes
that your
your mom made she's quite the skilled
craftsman
yes she's extraordinary and then it went
off the rails when one of our children
decided he was
a bit above it and she dressed him up
as sherlock holmes at his request yes
he accepted wait before so he said
at first he said pretty young right it's
like 11 maybe
he said i don't want to do halloween
anymore i don't i'm not interested in
candy i don't want to go asking people
for things i don't want anyway i'm not
doing this
so he dressed up as sherlock holmes
complete with the pipe and the deer
stalker hat or whatever it's called
um and instead of soliciting candy he
went up to doors and he asked each of
the households
if they had seen any suspicious
characters
and the thing is the funny thing is i
recall
in later years when we came by
that we were asked with the other child
who was still the younger child who was
still interested in doing this right we
were asked where where
that adorable odd child was when asked
about suspicious
where is he now he is now the producer
of dark horse podcast among other things
yes proving that just you know because
you've done terrible things doesn't mean
you can't find a
honorable position in society that's
productive
yeah um so uh see that
i i was trying to make a connection but
like i think the cat in the head is in
some ways the inverse of like both of
the kids do both of these things like
they think real things have happened um
or they imagine up real things and
they're going to tell their
fantastical story and then they actually
revert to the truth
and to think that i saw it on mulberry
street and then the cat in the hat
you know kids can actually believe that
crazy things happened like that
right and then uh when you know and
actually
they may just be deceiving themselves or
you know
there's a lot of reasons for kids to
believe that crazy things happen that
didn't
but at the point mom comes home they're
like
mom they she says
um you know what's going on here um they
are convinced the children that they
need to hide from her the truth when
in fact you know if if all of the chaos
that happens in the cat in the hat it
actually happened it's the children who
got out of control
and you know maybe with the help of a
babysitter who was too busy on her phone
or whatever
and now they're trying to hide hide all
of the evidence from their mom
uh you know there is no countenance it's
really it's really uh
risky business for children yes
um and then i guess before we talk and i
know we're going
way over here but before we talk about
some of the specifics of the
cancellation i would like to ask you
do you have a zans for cans oh you
should i sh i
i did i know that i should you should
yes do you have samples
yes this is a question that we pose to
each other rather frequently around here
i'm not quite sure why
but man one fish do you fish redfish
blue fish
uh i don't know what the lesson there is
beyond basically you know getting
familiar with language and playfulness
and uh and really language and
playfulness
yeah i mean i think actually that one
and i would have to go back to it to be
sure but the fox in
socks oh yes right the fox and socks is
not a lesson book
about the content it's a lesson book in
how to deal
with uh tricky linguistic construction
absolutely and i
i haven't found it on our shelves and
it's possible i somehow got rid of it in
our move but
for a long time i had a book um about
some of his er zeus's early playings
with language which probably included
some of those early racist cartoons
called the tough coughs as he plows the
dough
because i i'm not sure if he was an
american he may have been a naturalized
american because i think
english may not have been his first
language and i'm sorry if i'm getting
this wrong but as i remember it that
book
because if you think about this this the
title the tough coughs as he plows the
dough
it's four words that all end with ough
and so it was him learning english going
like
what is going on with this crazy
language where i have four words that
look like they should rhyme
tough cough plow doe which don't
none of them rhyme and how is it that
you end up
with a language like that and um so i
don't
i'm not positive that he wasn't born
elsewhere and
and we should have thought about that
before doing an episode on soosness
yeah i don't i don't know um but anyway
he he was he was fascinated with
language and
the and the fox and socks uh expands on
that also and
you know again that was a book that we
read to our children a lot and i don't
have it so i don't know why
yeah somewhere yeah
um okay so why are we talking about zoos
today
well um there are six seuss books that
won't be published anymore
um here is a headline from cnn
zack six dr seuss books won't be
published published anymore
because they portray people in hurtful
and wrong ways
okay um z thank you um
in this cnn report they say the study
also argues that they're referring to a
study that i'll get to here
the study also argues that since a
majority of human characters in dr
seuss's books are white
his works inadvertently are not center
whiteness and thus perpetuate white
supremacy
right perpetuate white supremacy yeah so
um learning for justice which is
this outfit here um
is um was called teaching tolerance
and it was formed by the sblcc the
southern poverty law center about 30
years ago
teaching tolerance has been proudly
renamed learning for justice
now because um they recognize now that
teaching tolerance is a
bad goal oh terrible bad goal and what
we really need to do is learning for
justice
so again zach i need my screen reader to
find what i'm doing here in just a
minute
um this crazy what you want to see yeah
i want to go back
how about you look at it without me
showing it because i need to find some
stuff
no no you okay go for it can you put it
up
i just want to point out the comparison
between soos himself and the joyous
presentation
of the world and this
marm sour it's time to talk about
dr seuss right it's to take your
medicine
we have to it doesn't matter how much
fun or how much you're learning from dr
seuss it's time that we talked about
what's deep in his past
right that is so absurd and so obviously
the wrong side of this argument yep
right yes yes i just want to call
attention that this is somebody
who has lost the thread and given up on
the idea
that um that there could be good things
in the world that we should just allow
to be for what they are
yes absolutely um i
i totally agree so one one thing from
this don't show me screen just yet zach
is the learning for justice center
says if you're thinking you need to burn
your favorite copy of the snitches or
the cat in the hat comes back
i'd really rather that you didn't we're
all about environmental safety
[Laughter]
if you're thinking you need to have some
important conversations with your
students you're absolutely right
their justification for not burning
books yep is that it's bad for the
environment well actually this is this
is also relevant to witches
because think about the fuel especially
if they've been eating crap food all
their lives
the stuff that's going to get
aerosolized when you are or
particular turn into particulate matter
that others might inhale if you burn
them
you should do so at least with a good
vent ventilation system
well certainly ventilation but i think
the the real point of the woke
revolution is that the burning of which
is is
only acceptable if it's done in a carbon
neutral way yeah so
offsets or something like that oh
yeah yes yes no i see a business model
here
yeah oh we could sell them
some kind of non-fungible
offsets blah blah blah oh it's a
business model for us
yeah oh okay totally i'm not sure i want
to get into that business model but okay
so here's um two more paragraphs from
this um insane
learning for justice piece but what
about the snitches they ask you can show
it if you want zack
in light of this new information you may
wonder about dr seuss books featuring
non-human characters
at teaching tolerance we've even
featured anti-racist activities built
around the dr seuss book the sneetches
but when we re-evaluated we found that
the story is actually not as anti-racist
as we once thought
and it has some pretty intricate layers
you and your students might consider too
the solution to the story's conflict is
that the plain belly sneetches and
star-bellied sneetches simply get
confused as to who was oppressed
as a result they accept one another this
message of acceptance
does not acknowledge structural power
imbalances it doesn't address the idea
that historical narratives impact
present-day power structures
and instead of encouraging young readers
to recognize and take action against
injustice
the story promotes a race neutral
approach
so the learning for justice organization
which was once
which is now called teaching tolerance
has once again
demonstrated they can't tell the
difference
they're now called teaching tolerance
and they were once called learning for
for justice is once
again revealed as so many of these
people
do that they can't tell the difference
between an individual and a population
they just they simply they're not
willing to or they can't tell the
difference they have no idea
so in listening to this
insanity yes i
cannot help but wonder about something
in myself no i feel like
i feel like i'm almost famously tolerant
and i feel like i'm getting to the end
of my tolerance at the point we're going
to play this game
over this stuff right yes
i just don't know how to file it because
god damn it this is too freaking
important right
this is a wonderful case of
a person with normal human failings who
overcame them
decided to pass on what he had
discovered
right has done uncountable good for the
world specifically with reference to
children
what he provided to the world is totally
democratizable
and we are going to cancel it over
you know infractions that are
that actually how do i say this
we have to be able to look at historical
artifacts that
are compromised by things like racism
and be able to say yes
that was 1942 that was 1928.
look how far we've come we have some
idea what our actual history was how bad
things were
how bad things weren't how fast we've
moved
and where we've ended up and we might be
able then to look forward and say
well what are we still getting wrong
right but if you're going to erase the
history if you're going to
make this frankly insane claim
that mere exposure to things that are
compromised by their position in history
things that show
some sign of common bigotry right
if you're going to argue that simple
exposure to those things is so
harmful that we cannot risk allowing
children to see
it they're going to have no idea what
actually happened
right frankly it is very useful as an
adult
that i periodically run into things that
surprise me
it is useful that i read darwin and i'm
a little bit shocked sometimes
right but he gets some stuff wrong you
know that i have to grapple with
fisher and his anti-semitism right
the fact of having these characters
legacy
right almost all the greats if they were
born before yesterday
right and you know i don't know how long
i don't know how long we can go we're
already canceling washington and lincoln
has anybody
noticed that there are gigantic
monuments to these men in washington
and jefferson how long before we discuss
whether those have to be removed
right that's clearly going to come and
the fact is
i'm sure they'll put up something
beautiful and propagandist
propagandistic in this place though i
mean no doubt
yes but you know what not yes but that's
ridiculous
well it is ridiculous
yes but this there is a monument not far
from those old ones
right there is a monument to the vietnam
war
dead that is a monument that
acknowledges
the ambiguity of history do we get to
honor these people
who fought for us in spite of the fact
that we largely now recognize that the
war was not
just that it was predicated on falseness
that it didn't need to be fought
these people lost their lives doing what
they perceived as their patriotic duty
and uh we the government [ __ ] up we
should not have been there
we should we the government are
responsible for the deaths of these
people
now it doesn't say that anywhere but
clearly the tone of the monument
recognizes that there's a gray area and
that we have to grapple with these
things and it seems to me that this is
implicit in all of
all of these questions and that the
impulse to erase the history is
specifically
a an instinct of those who wish to
fictionalize what happened
in order to make it sound much worse
than it actually was as bad as it may
have been
make it worse than it was in order to
justify other things that they are not
entitled to do
yep that's that's that's right um
let me just come full circle on the uh
what's happening with asus books right
now because um you know it is
it is the soos foundation or whatever
they're called who have decided to
permanently table six of these books and
they've become basically unavailable
um i went looking within a few hours of
their decision and at least one of the
books was um on offer for three thousand
dollars
uh on amazon and then it said not
available well then
amazon made the choice and ebay made the
choice not to circulate these things
and in an echo of our discussion on
andy noe's book not being available
locally here in portland
but minecomp still being available
mineconf is still available
on ebay um and so it's not like there's
a policy that says that things that are
coming as dumb as that policy would be
yeah things that are bad from history
won't be sold here
right that policy apparently does not
exist dr seuss is a no-go and
mind conf is still still cool no it's
it's a
to hearken back to the phrase that i uh
that i created back in the beginning of
the summer it's a society-wide don't
hurt me well
and i and i fear that that's what the
seuss foundation again whatever exactly
they're called
is doing that this is a this is a
slightly proactive but mostly
retroactive
um like please don't hurt me look at how
ahead of things we're getting we're
gonna get rid of these six books um a
couple of which i understand and i
haven't been able to find actually do
have some
um some racist imagery in them um but at
least the two that we've talked about
here don't
just not like why why are they getting
rid of um
and to think that i saw it on mulberry
street and um miguel against pool
yep um so um
i'm not sure exactly what prompted them
but every
article that's being written right now
is harkening back to this 2019 piece of
scholarship uh which is scholarship in
the same way
that um that uh lindsay pluckrows and
bogosians
important study on dog rape culture was
scholarship it's exactly that level of
scholarship i think and um
i you know i will probably uh catch some
crap for suggesting that but this this
is this is that level of garbage
um let's see where is it oh so
um yeah zach you can just show my show
my article
everyone is referring to this piece um
by ishizuka and stevens from 2019 called
the cat is out of the bag orientalism
anti-blackness and white supremacy in dr
seuss's children's books published in
research on diversity in
youth literature um and
you know it's it's a very long piece you
know they clearly put some time in
i'll give them that but one
just just one tiny thing that they say
and here is quote
our study sought to evaluate the claims
that his children's books are
anti-racist and was shaped by the
research
question how and to what extent are
non-white characters depicted in dr
seuss's children's books so
they do something that a lot of bad
science and a lot of
bad this isn't even science scholarship
do there where they say we had this
question
and this question is is is potentially
interesting i mean i don't
you know the claims that his children's
books are anti-racist that's already
that's already burdened there that's
already laden with
um with a conclusion but you start with
a question and then
you actually do something you know you
pivot and you twist and you you actually
do something
that becomes a very tiny narrow
instantiation of what
what one way that that thing might be
revealed in the world
which in this case is how non-white
characters are depicted in dr seuss's
children's books
so this is like this reminds me of
scientism
frankly this reminds me of so hayek
in who's an economist from the early
20th century
um coined this term scientism which we
talk about in our book actually
um uh in which he basically said look
there's all these people who aren't
doing science or who think they are
doing science but really aren't
um who look at look at what science
is and borrow some of the methods of it
and apply them
and then other people who are confused
can look on and say oh that sounds
science-y that sounds scientific
and it's this in some ways i think i'd
have to go back and really familiarize
myself with exactly what hayek was
saying he talked about it a lot
but i think he was particularly
concerned about the sort of the
elevation of
of actual science and the misapplication
of actual science to places where
it doesn't belong because there are
questions that you can ask where the
scientific method isn't the right
approach for sure
right um but what we definitely have in
modern times is even this kind of quote
unquote scholarship
seems to be playing around with
some of the supposed methods of science
and it's what it's done is it's borrowed
the worst of modern
scientific stuff which is so
reductionist which it said ah
i've got this question what can i count
what can i count oh
what i can count is how many of the
people are white
that's the thing i can count and it
fails to recognize that the thing that
you can
count is obvi often not the thing that
is an accurate indicator of whether or
not
uh what you are counting can tell you
anything about that question
yeah it doesn't get you there this is
wrong in two ways one
it isn't witches the sen
no the methodology is wrong of this
2019 paper of this study because one
let's say that you were doing you know
let's say that we were to evaluate the
um peaky blinders and whether or not
it was anti-black one of the best shows
on television a great show
right how many of the characters are
black
three certainly there's one prominent
character yeah but it is overwhelmingly
a white audience i mean white uh white
cast
okay you could conclude that that's the
result of bias or you could conclude
that this is
a story about birmingham
in the aftermath 1920s and 30s yes
birmingham england in the 1920s and 30s
and then it actually
does a pretty good job of you know
depicting this
scene plausibly you know it has an
over-representation of
gypsies wow i know right it's
anti-everyone but gypsies
is what is that's true um but okay so
the methodology the fact that you can
count something and that you find that
it is not what you expected doesn't say
what you think so just as with the
you know the demore era stuff james
damore google memo
right the idea that uh women may be
underrepresented
in the the engineering side
of google could mean that there's a
structural bias against women
gaining access or it could mean
something else like women have
preferences that don't tend to lead them
there as frequently and so they're
underrepresented so
you know the point is the counting
doesn't answer the question you're
you're
making a logical leap you're you're
engaged in a deductive fallacy
but the other thing that's wrong here is
that it isn't even meeting the basic
requirements
of science of advancing a hypothesis and
then testing it because they're testing
a question that they already know the
answer to so what they've done
is they've already landed on the answer
they'll come to well
not only are they conclusion driven but
they also even a casual perusing
of seuss which they've clearly done in
order to care enough about the topic
yeah tells them what answer they're
going to come out with so the point is
it's not actually a test you have to
count something that you don't know how
many you're going to find
right in order for it to be a valid test
you cannot
you know make an observation hey there's
a bias in this book and then test it by
measuring that same bias yeah yeah well
i mean i think
maybe this is wrapped up in your first
concern uh your first way that it's
wrong
um but this um this counting of trees
and pretending
you understand the forest is one of the
errors here and it's the
it's an error in a lot of modern science
that doesn't inherently have
some ridiculous woke bias in it it's
just
it's an era of the modern it's an error
of the modern era
to confuse what you can count with what
you want to know
yep now um i do think we have to be
careful it's not as if the racism is
absent but it's earlier right so
um well i think it's absent from most of
his books that's what i'm saying
is that the cancellation is about uh
trivial infractions that need to remain
just so that people have a sense of like
where we were and where
we are yeah the stuff that's really bad
and there is some stuff that's really
bad
zach do you want to show um
the cartoon there's a cartoon this is a
very early cartoon
um
[Music]
so yeah here we have the depiction of
africans right it's pretty offensive
i know what it reminds me of early
disney
right you'll find the same kinds of
tropes in disney uh
you know but when is this 20s
do we know when this is oh i
don't remember and you see just one
little thing that reminds me of later
seuss with that critter that's coming in
on the
in the upper right the mosquito yeah
yep so anyway this is really bad um but
we're talking about a person who
overcame bigotry and the fact
that he was so prolific in his books
explored so many different things
um oh that's really that's really quite
a cartoon isn't it
yeah it is but um but i mean it also
it's it
it's sorry but it's i've never seen this
before
and for those people listening um you've
got sort of
what maybe an african king with a lot of
crazy
racist uh indicators big lips
with tropes you've got the british
explorer being boiled there yet
we've got an african king who has a lot
of these racist indicators
and cooking a pot with another african
at it
a mosquito big mosquito comes comes
towards the king
he looks surprised the uh
white explorer who turns out to be in
the pot sticks his head up
not yet not yet cooked and
sprays the mosquito dead with some
insecticide
to the joy of the two africans who
um who you know it's it's racist they
don't they don't look
um as fully human as as the white guy
does
um but it's also i mean it's also that
you know
the white guy is not the savior here no
um but
that does seem to be what the emit what
the cartoon suggests
but he's also doing exactly the thing
you know he's doing the reductionist
crazy thing of like well just kill it
i'm sure it'll be fine well he i mean
he's being a dummy
he's protecting the person who's having
him boiled
so i think i think it's much more
interesting than that i think you know
he
my point is he's he's
produced this tool that people at the
time thought was going to be the amazing
saving grace
and you know this was just pre-ddt you
know this is
this is exactly the reductionist crazy
thing that gave us so many of the
problems of the 21st century where
people are now
um fat and stressed and unhealthy
because we've been told
that um that you know that nutritionists
and pharmaceutical execs and you know
exercise physiologists have all figured
out the one two three abc
thing that you need to do in order to be
healthy and just take these pills
eat these things make sure you get
enough carbs and this and that and the
other
and you'll be fine and um and and so we
land in part in the
in the crazy era that we're in okay um
it is a cartoon it is compromised
it may or may not mean various things
but we are stuck with this it is
from an early part of this person's
career
it does not appear to characterize his
later
thinkings about anything yeah um and
we could make the argument right i found
that cartoon
uh with a standard google search
we could make the argument that that
cartoon did you search like racist zeus
or something
um i'm trying to i think i searched
african
and soos okay um but in any case
we could make the argument that that
cartoon is offensive and it is
and that that offense could potentially
do harm which i guess it might
and we could make the argument that it
should then be removed from google
right no we shouldn't it is very
important that when somebody says
dr seuss had a racist past that i can go
and i can find that image and i can
assess for myself and when i do that
what do i come up with
yep he did okay that then allows me to
put the later stuff
in context that is a very important
thing to be able to do
disappearing the evidence is completely
unfair and this is increasingly
a trope of this woke nonsense you will
frequently now find
journalistic articles in which somebody
is reported to have said something
racist
but you can't find the quote to assess
for yourself whether it is or it isn't
and the problem is we know so many of
these accusations are
bogus that the idea that you can
just simply report well it was obviously
racist um and then
not say what the person said is uh
it is an obvious game to evade the
mechanism of evaluation
that's brilliant so says notorious
racist brett weinstein
right and i'm thinking back to this uh
chilling thing
you know in the hallway in that first
may 23rd 2017
event where i'm grappling with these
students i'm trying to get a handle on
what they think and what i should say so
that they will understand that they've
got it wrong
and this one guy a white guy not one of
your students one of the mob
right one of the mob somebody i never
met says you said some race
racist [ __ ] now apologize
and the point was you're just going to
skip the part
where what i actually said could be
evaluated
and the point is well we know you said
some racist [ __ ] you know it i know it
it's like
i didn't nope nobody who's paying
attention knows that
so um anyway zach do you want to put up
the um
cartoon uh some of the anti-fascist
cartoons
this is soos this is soos from world war
ii pre-war pre-r entry into the war
actual
actual anti-fascist actual anti-fascist
okay so
this is seuss and describe it for people
who are listening uh you've got a
picture of two
guys on a stage a
american guy with a america first
written on his jacket
with a smile standing tall if awkwardly
on the stage
and his beard is linked to
a guy a sort of um malformed
fat grinning apparently
german nazi with a swastika on his belly
and the person in an uh patriotic
american
hat is pointing at the beard that links
them together
he's like a carnival barker uncle sam
yeah carnival barker uncle sam is
um announcing to the audience and on
this platform folks those most
perplexing people the lads
with the siamese beard unrelated by
blood they are
joined in a manner that mystifies in the
mightiest minds of the land um
so anyway this is one of many
anti-fascist cartoons so again
the date is relevant here wait no zach
don't
don't no not yet please um
do we know when that's from it's it
feels super relevant
yeah it is super relevant to the story
but i believe it is just
before our entry into the war in the
couple years prior
okay so so if that is true and i don't i
really don't like doing this without
knowing exactly when that's from
if that is true that tells a terrific
story in which it would appear
that geisel that soos is basically
saying to the american government what
the hell are you doing you appear to be
on the side of the germans here
right and he does that many many times
he takes lindbergh to task
who was a nazi sympathizer he goes after
the america first movement which is an
isolationist
uh movement um so zach do you want to
show the um
okay here we have
an america first guy sitting in his
bathtub with
nazi fish um
[Music]
uh and a nazi crocodile
uh maybe positioned to scrub this guy's
back
and it says uh i think there's a nazi
octopus
lobster yeah there are lots of nazi
critters um
and basically and and the bathtub is
labeled american hemisphere
and it says the old family bathtub is
plenty safe for me the idea being that
we can't hang out in the western
hemisphere and
uh expect to be safe from the nazis but
the america first movement doesn't get
it
um do the next one zach
okay now here we have two figures
apparently carved into something
mount rushmore like one is clearly
a smug caricature of hitler
and the other is a bizarre and distorted
japanese person that i'm led to
understand does not
in any obvious way resemble any
leader like hirohito or anything like
that so
in this case what we have is those
figures are carved into the mountain and
says don't let them carve those faces on
our mountains
um by united states savings bonds and
stamps
um and so this is a
pro-war effort cartoon
now in it we can see two things we can
see that
soos is anti-fascist
that he is uh intervention
that he is patriotic that he has
distorted
the japanese villain uh much more
strongly than the german villain
evidencing
bigotry um so you know what are we to
make of a cartoon like this a cartoon
like this
contains uh the full complexity
right this is a person with bigotry
early in their
life a bigotry that they later overcome
you know referenced the earlier part of
this conversation about horton here's a
who
so in any case this is in many ways
the perfect demonstration of what really
happened in in theater geisel's case we
have
the receipts we've got the evidence of
what he what he went through
and what he became what it meant and
you're arguing
that the current attempts to disappear
the receipts
allows any story to be told allows any
story to be told
and it also um and
mind you i don't think that they are
done with the cancellation effort on
on dr seuss i think we will see more but
um the the fact is central
to the whole program of this woke
revolution
are two contradictory ideas that sit
right next to each other
right that white supremacy is our top
priority and we must act against it very
strongly and white supremacy cannot be
cured there's nothing we can do
if you're white you've got the disease
right so
this story actually tells us quite a bit
it says that you can go from a state of
bigotry
and you can arrive at a state of an
egalitarian
liberal-minded view of the world and
that that is a real transition where we
can
you know we can evaluate the man warts
and all and
get some sense of what is possible but
there's a reason that they do not want
us doing that and that reason is that
if it is possible to overcome your
bigotry
then you would have to ask the question
of which of us might have already
overcome our bigotry
right you couldn't just demonize us
based on our skin color you would have
to say
well i wonder if this person
uh has the disease or not and they don't
want to do that so they need the
simplifying assumption that nobody is
cured
and in order to get it they're
disappearing the the evidence and they
are going to fictionalize history
and you know it's enough
simply we simply cannot allow this to
happen and dr seuss this is such an
obvious example
right eskimo fish is what it is yes the
term
eskimo is antiquated and not a good term
but we should be able to go look at it
and say isn't that interesting that in
but every year mulberry street was
written 50 something
um that that term was in circulation
yeah i think it will come as a surprise
to almost everyone that eskimo is
also a term that we're not supposed to
be using anymore i haven't
but that's maybe neither here nor there
um i you know
i i object as we talked about early or
in the middle of this to the idea that
um
you know language changes by fiat it
doesn't it it changes as people change
what they believe and change how they
use language and it changes as the
generations move right like this is
this is part of what young people do is
that they take the language of their
elders
and they change it and the elders go
what are you doing and the young people
say we're you know
we're changing that's what we do so um
you had suggested
um that we
invite people to start using a hashtag
loose the seuss which i'm only concerned
about because i'm not sure that
i think people will end up hashtagging
lose the zeus
how about let loose the seuss
maybe that helps it still got loose in
it um
um but so isn't that the name of your
poem let loose the seuss
i guess it is yeah um
in any case yes the thought was that we
have people
tweet in susian rhyme
and that we pick a hashtag do we have
one that doesn't isn't compromised
well i was saying that we would use
hashtag loose the seuss l-o-o-s-e
the seuss s-e-u-s-s
and just encourage people to write susan
rhyme of any sort and
you know it's it's it is both
it has the potential to be both fanciful
and deep and there's plenty of seuss
that is not deep um but plenty that is
and it is all i think all of the books
that remain
to us now are indeed aren't indeed
fanciful you know this is not
it's not school marmie ever and uh
it does rhyme and have meter but it
plays around
in those spaces as well it doesn't it
doesn't simply adopt a simple
even you know rhyming metric and and
stick with that
yep um so shall we have them do that
on a particular day when we will have
the
we could have them do it on sunday
tomorrow sunday
um hashtag loose the seuss
and you can tweet in
susie and rhyme okay i'm i'm not sure i
mean most people would have seen this by
then
so i'm not sure that having a particular
day helps but all right
um at will i just think it's i think
it's interest it could be interesting to
see
if such a thing could could catch on and
we could get sort of
more fanciful more fabulous and
potentially more deep
um short poetry showing up um such that
anyone could search on that hashtag
hashtag loosevlasus
and um find some good stuff all right
excellent
so with that um we are going to take for
those of you watching we're going to
take a 15-minute break and come back
with our live q a as we always do
answering your questions
that you ask here in super chat um on
for those of you live on youtube email
our moderatordarkhorse.miter
gmail.com if you're not sure how to do
that
or with any other logistical questions
um please consider joining one or both
of our patreons mine heather heing has
the dark horse membership where we do a
two-hour private q a once a month the
last sunday of the month
bret on his has among other things um
two two hour conversations for people at
the higher tiers the
the one the second one for this month is
tomorrow
sunday at nine a.m nine a.m pacific
um you can go to
store.darkhorsepodcast.org for
some dark horse merchandise we will have
new stuff out
soon and um the clips channel
is uh is producing clips at a fabulous
rate given a fabulous
clip what a fabulous clip uh
and uh for those who are looking to
share um
shorter bits um or just interested in
shorter bits we recommend you going
there and if you
if if there's anything that you really
would like clipped again
uh email darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
and our moderator will pass that on
to our eclipse guy all right anything
else so as usual we encourage you to
love the people in your lives and eat
well and get outside for yeah
get outside absolutely all right be well
everyone
[Music]
you